Et là
ET là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ET là
[Musique]
Je vais dormir aujourd'hui, mon amour, je t'aime, casquette
une femme est décédée, l'équipe Gel reste en ligne
récolter
et nous avons gagné de la part de Dieu uni à la bonne colline gay
Clé aa
Je me suis déjà donné du mohawk gay baveux
photo choisis Sassa nous vivons je t'aimerai
doux levone de lui en train de sucer Hey Cousin
maremo c'est bien normalement l'argent
c'est normal
Et là
[Musique]
ET là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
J'ouvre le foie de poisson Cleiton, plus là toi
J'adore qu'ils donnent Cavalera dans chaque sens
L'oeil fou ne veut pas prendre de Fema et
Le monde Mayer Mayer ici, je ne suis pas un bébé
allaiter Hé, c'est doux, tu ne me verras même pas, j'adorerai
Je n'ai jamais aussi molareira même normalement
rouler en me regardant allaiter
[Applaudissements]
la Nemo KTM par son mari
ET là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ET là
Je n'étais personne, je suis Monkey, je l'ai mis là et
il m'a mis obstinément sur la table
Pourriture 1
et regarde l'amertume là-bas avec les PAC mejores
debout avec une crème qui ne meurt jamais
allaiter Hey, il y en a un là-bas, il me regarde allaiter Hey
si vous avez la peau Monalisa de Romário
Romário plus la loi du bien
et par la mer et le monde je me suis attrapé un de plus
crème même une
la papaye allemande et moi serons brûlés par la mer et
Je veux me voir en mer
Mary Kay vient me voir parce que j'ai trop travaillé
qui veut me voir
ET là
[Applaudissements]